Swap Hello everybo- oh my gosh, sorry, I sound like I'm about to fucking die.
But hello everyone!
Hello, hello, hello.
Today we have a very, very special guest here.
Who's gonna be our little teacher.
Who's gonna be teaching us how to do- use live 2D.
Uh, would you like to introduce yourself?
And I'm sorry I sound- I'm sorry for being late, guys.
My dog wanted walkies, and when my dog wants walkies, then I can't stop him, he's gonna pee.
Like, he needs to use the bathroom.
I can't stop that.
Anyway, would you like to introduce yourself?
Uh, yes, so, um, I'm NimYoi.
I guess it's a bit of a surprise that I'm here.
One viewer of mine named Alex, uh, won in the charity stream, and we commented me for the collab.
So, I'm very excited, but also nervous, because it's my first collab, and I think- Yes, it's your first collab, you liar!
No, first big collab!
Like, first real big one, so, like, um, I'm not super experienced with collabs either, I don't have money.
Uh, but I'm very excited to learn a lot.
Did you say I don't have money?
Did you- Money, money, money, money, money!
Oh, okay, I was gonna be like, oh my god, are you okay?
So, as you can see, or hear my English, it's the best, so be prepared for it.
I was just like, sorry, I have sick ears right now, guys.
Guys, I have- my ears aren't listening very well either right now, because my whole body is not okay at the moment.
They're like, don't- you can't ask that!
You can't just be like, aren't you poor?
I- I- I thought it was the most confusing thing ever!
I was like, wait, why did you say you don't have money?
Alright, for those who don't know, she is European.
European?
From, I believe, you're a German VTuber, right?
Hello?
Oh, I was like, are you like a German VTuber, right?
I'm a German- no, no, I'm an English VTuber.
But I'm from Germany.
Oh!
You mostly primarily- you say you mostly primarily stream in English.
Yes, exactly.
Because I want to learn more English.
And a lot of my clients are only English.
So, it's a good thing to stream in English.
Also, I can reach more people with rigging in English now.
Don't worry, even my chat was like, your English is better than mine, which is not- guys, it's not a high- it's not a very high standard to have better English than me, guys.
We all know I'm- English is my first language.
So, yes, huge shout-out to Alex for arranging all of this.
I'm sorry that it took so long to get all of this started.
My body is not okay, and it has not been okay for half a year now.
We were supposed to have a collab, like, last year.
And then I got sick.
And then I was- and then I went to Japan.
And then I got sick again.
And then I got better.
But then I- and then she was like, maybe we should reschedule.
And I was like, no more rescheduling!
And we are- We cannot- we cannot reschedule anymore.
I- I will- I can do this.
My body might be dying, but I can do this.
So, here we are!
Finally learning Live2D!
So, anyway.
So there was a lot of suggestions on what we were gonna do together.
We were, like, thinking we should play some games.
If we should, like, you know.
I remember, you know, I wanted to try Marvel Rivals at first.
And then- but then I thought, like, you know, since this is a very special collab for her and me.
I figured it should be more than just, you know.
We play just a game.
And since you are a Live2D rigger, and you are an artist.
I figured we go with a strong suit.
Like, you showing us how Live2D works, because I've never tried Live2D before.
So, if you see this on the screen, that's not mine.
I mean, that is you!
You are mine, guys.
Dragoons are mine.
But, no, guys.
I am not banning you.
I am not disowning you.
I meant to say, this is not my screen right now.
And she will be Live2D-ing a dragoon for us.
And showing us, like, the process of how it works.
Do you think you can get all this done in, like, one stream?
Yes, of course.
Woah, really?
Yes, this is a gift from me and my friend.
Like, we wanna give it off to you so you can share with anyone to have a jiggly bird.
Oh my god.
Can you give a toggle where, like, they can have, like, some jiggle physics, you know?
It will have lots of jiggle physics.
Trust me.
At least somebody has them.
That's the reason we are here.
At least someone gets to have them.
You know?
I'm just standing at first, but now I understand.
Oh, yes, because I'm right next to you.
Look, I have other physics, okay?
Like, it's somewhere else, okay?
It's somewhere else.
You have other jiggly physics.
Guys, no, no, no.
Let me move my tablet this way.
Let me...
So I'm not cum.
Let me move my tablet here so you guys don't wanna look at me, guys.
You have other jiggly physics.
Alright, so how long have you been a rigger?
For how long, you ask?
Yeah, yeah, how long have you been doing this?
Okay, for already, I think, around four years.
But when I started, I wasn't taking it so serious, so...
I think it's been since two years when I started really doing models for other people.
And, yeah, actually, I started rigging because I wanted to get a model for myself.
And back then, back in the days, there were a lot of riggers.
There was Ivan Vertex, yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But not many other people like now.
But then I never had time to do my own B2M model, so...
Wait, did you not rig yourself?
No, not in the start.
I never finished any rig for myself.
Oh, I see.
But you've learned so much and now you're doing it yourself now, too.
Yes.
I mean, I feel like being your own, like, pop-up has, like, so many advantages.
Because you can, like, add, like, you know, if you have an idea, you'll just be like, I'm gonna add this right now or I'm gonna add that right now.
It has many positive but also some negative points.
Like, if you are a perfectionist, let's say it like this.
But, yeah, what I mean is, like, you are never done with your rigging.
Like, really, never.
I still rig today on my model.
So, how many have you done?
How many have you done?
Oh, Lord.
I think... Wait, let me go on my website because I lost the card.
Oh, you have your own website?
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, it's just memyeye.com.
So, it's easy to find.
My clients are listed there, but let me...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14...
I think about now, there aren't everyone listed.
So, like, 30 models so far.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Out of how many years?
Actually, for 4 years, but like 2 and 3 years.
Oh, my God.
That's a lot of models.
That's a lot of skinsuits.
Yeah, I'm like a bunny.
You know...
Oh, my God.
Whoa.
Are you pregnant right now?
Always.
There is no time when I'm not.
Oh, you're never not pregnant.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
You're never...
Oh, man.
Let me move the tablet back.
Now I know why it's like that.
It's always...
It's a special...
Sometimes I'm questioning myself why do I have fox ears when bunny ears...
You should be a rabbit.
I mean, you can make that your new... another outfit.
I was thinking about it because it would truly fit.
Oh, my God.
All right.
So, how do you first... What do you first do when you...
Okay.
What we are first doing...
I just tried a little bit around before we start the stream just to look what I'm aiming for.
And I can show you what I'm aiming for.
I will redo some stuff.
But we have here some jiggly things.
We will adjust that.
But I was thinking of going for this one now.
We are going to delete everything and we do some parts.
I was trying around but first of all, we start with the dragoon's eyes.
So, they can blink.
Like here, this one.
Oh, my God.
I'm already so lost.
There are so many texts on the screen.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my... No, no.
Keep it at the top.
Yeah, yeah.
Leave it up here.
No, no.
I like that.
No, no, no.
We should... Yeah, yeah.
Let me help this one.
Yeah, no, no.
That's perfect.
Guys, that's actually perfect.
Yeah, we kind of have to like this.
That's my special dragoon right there.
He's special.
A very special fellow.
He's my very special little guy.
Mama said I'm special.
I really love those eyes now.
This is a very amazing idea.
What we also can do is, of course...
When he goes down...
What we are going to add is like a teabag.
You can imagine like a small teabag.
Oh, that's so cool.
So...
Like a little teabag, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, it's cool.
Yes!
And then, whenever they do something nicer...
Maybe Marvel Rivals, you know?
They can do something like that.
It's so good.
I love that.
Oh, my God.
You can just do that?
That's so fast.
That's... Oh, my God.
That's a professional right there.
She did that in like 5-10 seconds.
Like, what the hell?
This is so like... And then, imagine you do the teabag.
And that's a...
Imagine...
That's what disrespect would be like.
It's so beautiful.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
You should wag his tail too, right?
Yes!
That's of course possible too.
We have the tail separator too.
You can have like a wiggle here.
But I will add some physics to it.
So, let me show you.
Tail wag.
We add this as like the automatic thing here.
So, we don't add anything on here.
But then, we add the tail wag physics to make it more jiggle.
We love the jiggle, you know?
Oh, you can jiggle it too?
Yes, of course.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Can like I have him like...
Can I have the drag... Can we have a toggle where the dragoon holds like two basketballs?
And then, the basketballs are made of jello.
So, then when he goes up and down, it's like jiggle physics.
I'm sure it's possible.
You can send me over what you need and I can finish it after the stream.
No, no, no.
We can just get like a PNG of a basketball.
And then...
We don't need a draft.
Let's get a free stock photo of a basketball.
And then just copy and paste it into the arms.
And then we just make it like... It's like a water... Oh, it's like a water balloon.
Oh, wait.
No, a water balloon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then the dragoon will hold like water balloons.
Oh, we get PNG of a water balloon.
And...
Oh, my God.
This is not... Is this not what you wanted?
Is this...
Hilarious.
You have to... You have crazy ideas.
Yeah, yeah, like... Yeah, we're ballers, guys.
Alright, okay.
I'm going to look for... If you're done with the jiggle physics, we can add the basketball into...
Oh, wait, wait, no.
We should do water balloons.
It makes it more natural.
Oh, water balloons.
Okay.
That makes it... Whoa!
It's so sm... What the... Wait, what happened?
What did you do?
I just looked away one second and now the tail's wagging.
I was just using like a path deformer.
You can...
Click on this and then you can make a path deformer.
Wait, can you make it into a cool ass?
Can you... Actually, can you make it into a...
Oh, my God.
Wait, no.
Yes.
Can you make it into a cool ass?
Like...
You're insulting like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, like an ass.
Just make it...
Wait, no.
Wait, I want him... I want the dragon to be able to elongate their tails.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You have too much of...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should be able to make their tail longer as a toggle when they're excited.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what?
What?
You told me, like, no.
Yeah, yeah.
How do you do that?
No, no, it'll be funny.
It'll be...
Okay, we can make it like tail...
Yeah, yeah.
Excited.
And let me make it as a blend shape.
Yeah.
And then just take this.
Oh, wait, let me...
Wait, this is a zero.
Oh, my God.
Wait, maybe I should be a rigger, guys.
Maybe...
Oh, my God, guys.
If I knew how to do that, I'd do that every...
If I knew how to do that, I'd rig these every day.
Yeah, let me make it more pretty here.
Personal request.
So, this is this excited tail.
Oh, my God, it's...
Like...
Oh, I'm happy.
See?
I'm so happy.
Nice.
That's great.
This is celerial.
Can the wagon tail, when the tail is long?
Can you wagon?
I can make it work.
Actually, this is the cool thing about blend shapes, actually.
Because I can use a blend shape right now.
The physics from this one will work on this.
But if I make, like, a tail wag long, you see?
Yeah.
I can use it for this state of tail.
And then we can...
I need to just...
Oh, my God, it's beautiful.
When the dragoon is happy to see...
I only need to get my life...
Oh, it was on a different monitor.
This is why I didn't see my...
Okay, so...
We add this point here.
Yeah.
If Live2D lets me.
Here.
Change this to this.
Whoops.
Here.
And then we can...
Oh, my God, look how flexible your tails are.
They are super flexible.
Oh, my God, look at...
Oh, my God, the tail can twerk on its own.
Look at it go.
Wow.
You can do so many forms with the tail.
And this is so funny.
What we want to have...
We need a specific movement for it.
So it doesn't deform weirdly with the physics in the end.
So we just do a tiny bit.
Okay.
You always need to think about that you use the power arm and not be on the main.
Yeah.
It's like...
Stop drawing.
Why?
You are on the same layer.
This is like...
This can happen actually with Live2D too.
If you don't change the power arm.
Okay, so we have this for the longer tail.
Now...
Wait.
We go to the...
To the magic...
Wait.
Here.
Limit blend shapes.
And we have tail long for a sec.
We want to have it here.
Look at this magic happening in front of us.
Like now we don't want that tail long.
Oh my god.
Look at it.
It's like a little dog tail.
It looks really weird.
Wait.
Oh no.
I forgot how to rig.
What's this one?
I swear to god.
This is always me when I'm rigging.
There's so many options to pick from.
Wait a minute.
I have the better idea.
If I'm too lazy to do things like this.
Yeah.
To do some different stuff.
I just copy paste the tails and make a toggle with tail switch.
And then we have one toggle that works with the...
Wait.
So we have here tail long.
And we make a toggle here.
Tail long.
This is just for a toggle then.
So the tail switch to...
Oh my god.
Now you have two tails.
Oh lord.
Oh my god.
You're in echidna now.
Wait.
I want that as a toggle.
Now you're in echidna.
But like for the tail instead of the other part.
Looks like a scissor.
Imagine.
Oh my god.
You're like Knuckles, guys.
You're just like Knuckles.
You guys like Sonic, right?
I like Sonic.
Wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah.
We should...
I want that as a toggle, a second tail.
The second tail.
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Can we name this Tail 2?
Then let's have like Tail 2.
I'll add later the Tail Excited.
I mean...
Oh, Tail Excited?
Yeah.
So, like...
What if we put a knife into his hand?
He will be like...
Oh, yeah.
What?
Holding a knife.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But like water balloons first, of course.
Water balloons.
Angry chicka.
We can make it angry too.
Let's first focus on the physics and then on the toggles.
Okay, true, true.
That's more important.
Sorry.
We got distracted there, guys.
You need to jiggle first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, guys.
We got very distracted over other things.
Sorry.
Our priorities were very different.
Let me grab some water balloons stock photos real quick.
Water balloons for us.
Okay, so what are we doing next?
We are...
It is like looking up thing.
Because right now it goes down and now it goes up.
And of course we need some physics for up and down physics.
Because it would be boring if it doesn't have any physics.
Yeah, yeah.
That's true.
Then we add some physics for going down.
Then for going up.
So what I like to do for going up and down is adding some like animated feature.
Like if it goes down, it stretches.
Like it goes a little bit...
Yeah, yeah.
That would make sense.
That makes sense.
And then of course what I like to do for the second part is focusing more on the body related physics.
Because we want to keep it simple here.
So...
We have this one here more.
We add the tummy look.
Oops.
Oh my god.
Because right now...
Oh my god, you're so jiggly.
Oh my god.
We are not done.
We are not here yet.
There comes lots of more jiggly physics.
Oh my god, you're so...
You're so jiggly.
I think like...
Okay, when we turn to the right and we turn to the left...
You should be able to see a little bit of the butt.
You what?
Okay, so how far can he turn right or left?
So you know how like...
Okay, so like you know how like...
You know like the little...
When you turn to the left or right...
Just a little the butt is showing.
So like you know like a little bit of the ass.
And...
I mean we could get the...
Get the cheeks there, you know?
Oh my god.
Just like a little bit.
You know like when you turn left and right just a little bit.
Just the right cheek there.
Just a little bit of a cake.
You know like Venom.
Oh, Venom!
Yeah, yeah.
Have you ever seen...
Yeah, just like Venom's cakes.
Just photoshop a Venom's ass.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we can photoshop Venom's cake into...
Oh my... See, we're cooking, guys.
We're cooking.
We're gonna give you Venom's implants.
Can you see how cute this little guy is?
Oh my god, it's so cute.
Wait, should the eyes also like...
Like squish a little bit there?
Oh yeah, let's add the squish for the eyes.
Yeah, yeah.
Let me make it separate.
Eyes squish for...
Oh, it's...
Okay, yeah.
Eye...
Squish.
I'm gonna be called Eye Squish.
Let's make it here.
Oh yeah.
Guys, we're learning so much.
Can you stop me from cooking?
I'm making you guys even better.
I'm improving the...
I'm making the ideal dragoon.
It's like how Adam is like the peak human design.
I'm creating peak dragoon design right there.
The perfect specimen.
We're going to add some eye physics, like the eye jiggle on the eye opening thing.
Because I think this could be a little bit cuter than...
I think if we put it on this one here, it could distract a little bit on the body self now.
Yeah, yeah.
The mouth, the face area is like...
Feels weird a little bit when he goes up and down.
It looks very like he's only moving his head, but we are...
Missing still the other part here that moves a bit with it down.
To make it more...
Deaf?
Oh my gosh.
It sounds like I say deaf.
I don't mean deaf.
So, wait a minute.
What can we do?
Guys, I found water balloons, guys.
We can make him turn up and down as you can see.
This is just very simple made, but...
You can see what I'm meaning here, like...
Wait, that's so good!
So we can do the left and right, yeah?
Yeah, the left and right!
Fabulate prep left and right, or are we doing that now?
It's possible, actually.
Like you turn in this direction.
Yes!
And like this here.
And then you can add a little butt crack here.
Add a little kick there.
What am I doing here?
Wait, are we giving venom implants or are you gonna draw the lump?
I'm thinking.
I mean, the venom things would be so funny, but maybe not fitting.
Okay, true.
Oh my god!
He's all jiggly.
I think we actually... Wait a minute.
I have the idea to add this here.
More to the angle part.
And have the angle part here on the physics.
Oh my god.
Wait, so right now if I want...
Look at him fucking go.
What a lad.
Alright, anyway, I'm just sending in the water balloons.
So, and we add this here.
And now we work with the draw order again to show how I've done it.
It's like... Wait.
So, like first of all the small head thing goes a little bit up.
Yeah.
Then it goes behind the head.
And then we have... I need to see still.
Now we need to edit the body still to have it working for this.
Guys, are you writing it down?
Because I'm not.
Oh my god, it's like watching magic happening in front of me.
Why don't we upload...
Oh my god, you're looking up!
Like, it's super simple, mate.
Oh, that's so cool!
But if it works, it works.
Oh my god.
Wait, would the hair be a little bit more to the center if he looks down?
We can do that, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes.
A little bit rotational here.
So, maybe.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that's so cool!
Oh my god!
Like, look.
Oh my god, look at you go!
This is so adorable.
Not gonna lie, it's cute.
Okay, of course we make the...
The chicken arms here.
We'll make two with the physics.
Oh my gosh, you did this so fast, guys.
That was like done in like...
In like five minutes.
Like, what the fuck?
I can't believe it's only like 30 minutes of rigging and also we were also very distracted on other stuff too.
These are things that happens.
Not gonna lie, always happens.
Oh wait, what the...
Oh my god, that's so cool.
Now he's moving his...
Like, he's looking down.
Look at him go.
Look at him, look at his stance up.
No, it's a weird...
This is a group effort, guys.
Giving him some...
Owl legs.
Like, imagine.
Or else, like...
Imagine.
No, no, no, not like that.
I think this looks fine so far.
Yeah, this looks fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's let us adding...
Adding more of his knees visible.
Oh my god, look at you go.
You're like...
Look at your stance, guys.
Wah, wah.
It's so...
It's so funny.
It's the squats and dragoons, come on.
The power stance right there.
He looks up to others.
Or down to others from his position.
Oh my god, look at him.
Oh my god, wait, and then...
Elongate the tail.
Oh my god, the two tails too.
And those possibilities.
What's up?
I'm the...
I am a good idea person, okay, guys?
I'm basically...
I'm basically like my idol, Thomas...
Thomas Edison.
Wait.
Is that his name?
So now, look how he looks, how...
This is already so squishy.
Oh my god, he's so squishy.
Oh my god, look at him.
It's so adorable.
Oh my god.
You know, you're like Tesla...
And I'm like Thomas Edison.
I need to...
I need to say something.
I'm...
Don't tell anyone.
This is our project that we made together.
We made this.
I'm so innocent, I don't know.
I'm special.
That's right, Tesla.
My mom tells me always I'm a special person.
You're very special.
Now, can you send that file to me while I claim...
Oh no, baby!
The copyright.
I'm a slow...
I'm a slow one.
Oopsie, oopsie, oopsie.
I'm not Tesla, I'm more cool.
You're more cool than Nikolas Tesla?
Oh man.
Rest in peace, Nikolas Tesla.
Oh my god.
Wait, can we like inflate the dragoon?
Yes.
Look at this.
And now he always gets this one.
No, okay, not like that.
No, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's like a toggle.
That's like a...
That's what toggle games like, to give him...
A real big brain.
Oh my god, wait!
There is so many possibilities here.
There's so many possibilities.
That's the issue of being a rigger.
There are so many possibilities.
Guys, if I learn how to do live 2D...
Imagine what I can do.
Imagine the power you would have.
Oh my god.
How do we inflate it?
I mean, what's also possible is to make like...
Wait a minute.
Long fail.
Oops, this is caps.
Long fails.
One.
Stop saying...
Okay, how do we make him fat?
I mean, this is also possible.
Oh my...
I was thinking now of making him real long.
Oh wait, no, that's great!
Wait, I love that!
Wait!
Hello.
Mama calls me her big boy.
Wait, wait, wait.
How does this end?
Oh my gosh, hello.
Wait, wait, wait.
Then we put the face up top.
Yes!
Wait a minute, I need to...
This is what I mean with...
Stop, stop, you are on the wrong layer.
I never choose a layer.
Long face.
Let's do this as a toggle and put up the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pants.
This is what happens when long goon and regular goon get married.
They create an abomination.
Then we...
Then you can look like...
Oh my god, wait, that's so good!
Wait.
Wait for his hair back up top.
Oh my god, can you push the yellow part to a higher note?
Which yellow part?
The white part, higher.
The white?
Of course we can.
Of course.
Mama cost me her special big boy.
Here we are.
Okay, what does that look like?
Actually, it's this way.
So now we have this one, then...
We have long face.
Oh my god, it's so good.
Motomoto likes you.
You look so funny too.
I'm so excited, and then...
He's very excited.
It's so funny.
That's so good.
That's so good, I love it.
I love it.
What else do we have to do here?
Okay, so now we can add...
Oh wait, first of all, we didn't finish the tail.
Oh true, we were so distracted with everything else.
I can't believe we forgot the tail.
How could this happen to us?
Poor tail.
Poor little tail.
Wow, I wonder how we forgot the tail, guys.
What could have caused us to forget about it?
When we get there, so now we have...
We can make the tail excited.
Here's the tail, wait, let's see.
So now if we, let me see if this works.
Alright.
Where is it?
Ah, here.
Tail excited, I need to choose the tail wag here.
So now we can see the tail wag.
Guys, don't worry, I did not forget the water balloons, I sent it over.
I sent the PNGs over.
Like now, if he's excited, we can make his tail more jiggly.
I just need to add more physics to it.
I love it, I love physics, guys.
Or we just add the tail.
Physics, body, y, x, y.
Physics is so fun.
Physics are the most funny thing alive to me, because you can just...
Like, let me show you, like, what happens if you push the physics way too far.
Oh, what?
What do you mean by that?
Like, he really jumps.
This is the maximum physics.
Like, okay, I could go even more, but...
You can see the difference from this to this.
And now, let me tell you, if you rig breasts, it can be very, very...
Special.
Like breasts flying above a whole screen.
Even more special?
Yes.
It can be dangerous.
Oh my god, oh my god, Dragoons, you can be even more special.
Like, with those balloons, we can make funny things to happen.
You see that?
She knows about the water balloons.
So, let me show you, like, now when the body moves, we can see this little, small...
Oh my god, look at you, you're animated.
That's so cute.
Oh my god, it's so cute!
And of course, we want this with those...
Arms.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Little arms.
Let me see, let me see.
Actually, we also can let them talk, by the way.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, no, I love that!
No, no, no, it should be...
Like Canadians.
Wait, what's the other option?
What's the other one?
The other option would be more subtle, like the mouth, really.
Like, going...
Oh no, no, I like the first one.
I think, yeah, I think it's more funny to do...
Yeah, yeah.
With the Canadian dragons.
And then you make it like...
Like Canadians.
Oh my god.
Onto this.
So, like, it's so funny.
Oh my god.
We make it work, we make it nicely work.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we add some arm physics.
Arm...
Arm, what?
One is enough.
Oh, I have arm physics already.
Wait a minute.
I got bamboozled!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
So now we add some arm physics to make it even more cuter and jiggly.
Because it's important to have a jiggly fella.
Of course, jiggle physics is everything, guys.
It's everything.
Yeah, see?
I have jiggle physics too, guys.
Look at that.
So, we have...
Those little tiny arms.
Yeah.
So, like, we have one ear ready.
So let's arm arm.
We bet that for the left and right, those legs too and stuff.
So, let me add this on.
This is like the percentage of the effect of this you set up for the physics on each angle.
Like how much it's getting used, you can say.
Are you guys taking notes?
I'm saying uh-huh, but I'm not really understanding that much, but like uh-huh.
But you can see the jiggle.
So you put numbers in and then jiggle starts.
Yes.
Oh.
And if the jiggle happens, we are all happy.
Oh, I get it.
I understand now.
Are you sure?
Yeah, yeah.
Numbers in, jiggles up.
Exactly.
Yeah, yes.
Guys, see?
I can learn.
Guys, I get it.
I get it, guys.
So, we return this.
And now we add this part.
And this part.
And then we see...
Like now we have those small, tiny, fluffy physics.
Oh my god, look at you.
Isn't that cute?
That's so cute.
That's actually so cute.
Alright, should we do left and right now?
Or is there something else?
Yes.
Okay, so we know what we want for left and right.
You know that you want a butt?
Yeah, I want like one butt cheek showing at least.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Like, first of all, we add...
These angles.
And when we are done with the body angle, like...
Wait, can the tail...
Where is the tail?
I can't see the tail.
Oh no, she lost the tail.
Oh no, you can't get excited anymore, Draco.
She lost the tail.
What will she do?
Wait, so...
How will the dragoon get excited?
That's a very important question.
So, right now we have this here.
Actually, if we do this here right now...
One little part moves... Wait.
No, this needs to be lower.
You want that.
There's a little bit behind the other hair.
Yeah.
It's a hair thingy.
I don't know, like...
You know?
Wait, shouldn't it be like to the back when he turns?
Like the hair?
I think so, yes.
Like, here.
Shouldn't it move to the left side, the hair?
Because of like, perspective?
Actually, yes.
But with the round birdie object, it can be a little bit more stylized.
Oh, I see.
Okay, that's fine.
It's a very special bird.
Okay.
No way, that looks too weird.
Yeah, because right now, if we go logical on this one, it would go so much in the back.
It will look a little bit weird.
Actually, on a round object, it wouldn't move much.
It's a very special bird.
Weird.
That's what you say!
Not me.
Let's stop for a moment.
You agreed, you're part of the problem.
I'm not.
You're part of the problem, you're controlling it.
I mean, that's kind of true.
But look at him.
Oh my god, okay, that's cute.
That's cute.
I like that.
So...
Of course, we add this part here.
Oh my god.
Look at you go.
Oh, wait.
I can't wait for my favorite part, guys.
I feel like your favorite part has something to do...
This is my second favorite part.
We haven't done my favorite part yet, guys.
So...
Of course, we switch the inner part to here.
The white tummy part.
Because the tummy part needs to be more round.
And then we need to add the armys because right now they are stuck to their place.
No one will stop me.
This is for charity.
You hate charity, guys?
Wow, you want to stop charity?
That's fucked.
We have this here.
Like now we can look...
Like now we need to see how much we can connect those corners with each other to make it work.
But it's simple because we have here a simple thing.
It doesn't need to be...
Wait.
Let me see if we can get this behind a little bit.
Oh, yeah.
This is here in front still.
And then this goes a little bit to the back.
Because after a certain point...
Yeah, they should go behind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what?
Magic!
Look at that go!
Like now he can turn a tiny little bit.
Oh my god, magic!
Look at that!
It still looks a little bit fake to the side here right now.
Like it has...
I'm so confused what I'm doing.
I think you're doing great.
In my head it looks great.
You know, the thing with making subtitles is you do it again and again until you think it fits.
It's the magic behind.
Taking a lot of time.
So we have just this part here.
This will be covered.
The weird movement of the hair will be covered with physics.
You know, like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The tail goes wild.
The tail goes vroom.
Alright.
It's so adorable.
Yeah, it's so cute.
Wait, shouldn't the other arm also move to the left too?
To the side a little bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was thinking too, but I choose that this goes behind the body because it's already on the side here.
And this is so, like, more near the face.
So I thought if I go too far to the side it could look weird.
Oh yeah, that's true.
It'll be weird, yeah.
Alright.
This is what at least I was thinking right now.
Now it actually looks good.
That it might be a little bit far down.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's a real tough decision what to do because sometimes it looks a little bit better if you do it a little bit style-wise.
Yeah, yeah.
And not like how it is meant to be in real life.
So, let me add some physics on this part.
My god, how... so many physics, guys.
Yeah, and even... this is just a small part.
Like, I don't add too many physics here because we want to keep it simple to finish it in one stream.
But otherwise, like, the normal VTuber models, they have so many physics.
Like, you can scroll so long on this parameter thing.
Like, having 100, 200 parameters, just one model.
Sounds not so much, but it is.
Wait, how much is this?
This one here?
Yeah.
Not much.
Like, I don't have the body angles here.
We have head angle X, Y, Z.
I open, close.
I smile or something.
I could delete too because we don't need that.
We can have eye physics added.
I love the eye blinks.
Like, how does this look?
This is amazing.
Beautiful.
And then, beautiful movement.
Guys, this was our idea, guys.
You can tell this is... we did this together.
You had the great ideas, right?
Yeah.
Wait, so how do we do the cheeks?
The cheeks.
So, whenever they turn around like this, let me try to get...
This is a very spiky cheek like this, imagine.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, and then like a little... you can just do a little butt showing, like just a tiny little bump.
Do you mean like in front, like here?
Okay, so this is... Okay, I'm gonna do it on paint.
Okay, so this is my vision on how I think we could do it.
Wait a minute, I need to turn.
I wanna see what you're doing.
Wait, wait, wait.
I need to see.
I'm drawing it on paint right now.
This is my vision.
I'm scared to see it.
I'm so scared.
Okay, okay, okay.
Show me, show me.
I posted it in the chat.
This looks... special.
Wait, wait.
I think we can do it.
I have an idea, I have an idea.
Guys, this is what I sent.
I'll show you guys what I sent here.
Let me add it.
Let me open Photoshop so I can show you how...
Not I can show you, I will add the butt cheek for it.
Okay, nice.
Okay, so guys, this is what I sent here.
I was like, so this is my vision on how I think it could look like.
And I sent you this.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
We are going to do this.
Okay, so we have this one here.
It almost looks like the model.
That's what I'm saying.
It almost looks just like it.
So we want like...
Oh my god, yes!
We want another butt cheek like you have the butt crack here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just a tiny one showing on the side.
Okay, okay, I'll use this one and copy paste it for the side.
Okay, but that's so tiny.
It's got to be lumpier.
Okay, okay, you want a big butt.
Yeah, yeah.
No, we want a big butt.
Imagine.
Wait, wait, wait.
That looks like he has something going on.
Wait.
Maybe like...
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's good, that's good.
That was good.
No, no, no, just a little bit more.
No, that's too much.
Oh wait, this was too much?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no, wait, wait, wait.
This one?
I mean I can squish it to...
And then we have like another butt showing up too.
So like, it looks like he has two butts.
So like, you know, he has two butts.
Sorry, two butts.
I want to ask right now why two butts?
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
So then like the other butt is just like barely peeking, you know?
Wait a minute.
Yes, yes, yes.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah, you get it, you get it.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
We have a beautiful butt.
Like he's turning.
Yes!
What are you looking for?
Oh my god, yes.
That's so good.
The vision is there.
It's there.
It's so pretty, right?
It is so nice.
Let's add those two butt cheeks here.
Yes, it's beautiful.
It looks just like my vision right here.
It looks exactly like what I said, guys.
So we have this one.
And then we draw here the butt cheek out.
So we have...
What?
Okay, and now we are going to export this beautiful butt cheeks.
Yeah.
Into the model.
There you go.
Guys, look at that.
My vision was like... It was fucking perfect.
Like what I drafted out to the real thing.
It looks... It's just one to one.
It's exactly one to one.
Dragoon butt cheeks.
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
Oh, true!
We should add a little highlight to it.
A little white shine.
The white shine... Oh, no problem.
We can do it.
Oh, yes!
Let's make the white shine to it.
That's no problem.
Here we are.
Good ideas.
There's no bad ideas, guys.
Let's do this here.
Oh, my gosh.
Like...
Look at this.
Oh, my God!
Yes!
It should be both of them, right?
Yes, yes.
I have the shine separated, so the shine connects with the butt.
It's super special.
Save.
Underneath this one.
Then we save this one.
This one.
And then we come...
I have so many things here.
Okay.
Dragoon butt cheeks.
Oh, my God.
Here we are.
We have the butt cheeks here.
Oh, my God.
It looks beautiful.
I'm so excited, guys.
I feel like... It looks like he's touching his...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
He should... He's spanking his butt.
Oh, my God.
No, he should.
He should...
You feel like... You see that?
This is...
Happy to be a Dragoon?
Oh, you better be happy with what I'm doing right now.
It is so... Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Do we have another one?
That should be a toggle.
You know, like those animations and stuff that you can do?
There should be an animation where he just caresses his butt cheek.
I think... Wait.
Okay, now I have it.
I was curious.
Like having his...
Yes!
That should be... Can you add an animation for that?
Where he does that?
Can you add an animation for that?
Because I know some skin suits have animations.
Yes!
Okay.
I was distracted for a bit.
I was distracted.
Okay, don't get jealous.
She's the one that's doing it.
She's the... What do you mean?
I just smacked the cheek.
She fucking caressed it.
I need to... It was looking at me like it wanted to be you.
Look at it.
I've gone too far.
This is a group effort.
Imagine having those butt cheeks like...
Like...
No, okay.
This needs to stop.
Oh my gosh, this is too much.
What do you mean this is too much?
I mean, I was slapping his butt cheeks together.
I mean, that's fine.
Oh my gosh, imagine if you turn more... Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have the idea.
She has more ideas.
So, right now the butt would be... I mean, logical would be here, but...
Let me have it here behind.
Then...
Comes here.
Wait, let me...
I think we need to make a toggle with this position.
Oh, true.
I think it could be weird from the moving...
Yeah.
Like, to the moving one here.
But, let's make it a toggle butt cheek toggle.
Oh, that's true.
That's so true.
A toggle just for the butt.
Oh, I like how you think.
Then he...
Wait, and then we make something like this with...
Chicken...
Arm...
Butt touch cheek.
So, we make an idle for it, then.
So, how do we want to have...
Like, we can make...
Like, first of all...
How would she get in trouble?
It's a fucking chicken.
I don't...
If Witcher or anything would do it, I mean, like...
That would be weird.
This chicken is a dragon.
How would she get in trouble?
I mean, actually, maybe I could be a little bit careful with...
No, no, no, that's...
This one here?
No, no, no, no, that's...
I'm sorry.
That should be an animation.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't...
This is so hilarious.
It's so hilarious.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
But...
Let's see.
What has happened to us?
You have become...
You have evolved to something even greater.
Now...
We add the...
Butt...
Appearing toggle.
The butt appearing toggle.
I mean, what should I call it?
Like, butt toggle?
That's too boring.
Butt appears.
The butt jumps here.
Wait, I have the idea what happens when...
Oh, wait.
We need to...
We were...
Reflect.
Because right now I was doing this.
So now it appears and we won't have...
Like...
Appearing out of nowhere.
You just came back from butt implants, guys.
Welcome back, the surgery was a success.
I have the idea.
Oh my god.
Oh no, what if...
It was a success, guys.
Oh no, I have a...
I have a very evil idea.
Oh, nice.
I love your ideas.
Oh no, I...
I'm scared.
I can't do this.
Okay.
Guys, that wasn't me.
That wasn't me!
I can't...
Man, you are German.
After this idea, okay?
If no one would say it right...
Slap the butt or anything else.
Holy fuck.
I can't do this at all.
I ghost right up to hell.
Fuck.
Oh my god.
What do you mean, I did this?
I did it also.
I just...
I'm sweating so...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Actually, I only wanted to rig as a toggle, like the butt comes out, okay?
This was my first intention.
But then, it came to my mind...
Wait a minute.
What if...
Oh, yes, yes.
Sure.
I can't stop thinking of it anymore.
You're haunting my dreams.
Yeah, yeah, let's just say that.
Shame on me!
I did not do anything there!
I just wanted butt cheeks, guys.
That's all.
Okay, okay.
But where do we put the tail?
This is a good question.
What if we do it...
Wait, wait.
Should we put the tail?
Yeah, yeah.
No, no.
We should put it...
It would float up, because he wants to show the assets, you know?
And that looks very wrong.
That looks...
It should like float up, because he's presenting it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like this?
No, just...
No, stop.
No, no, no, no.
Especially when you elongate the tail.
We can't have the tail with the butt cheeks.
Okay, okay.
So like, when the butt cheek shows up, the tail disappears.
Yes.
Can you attach the tail in the front?
It's getting...
It's getting very, very, very, very, very, very problematic.
Okay.
Okay, so when the butt cheeks comes out, the tail like gets absorbed, so the butt cheeks gets bigger.
So like, that's why the tail's gone.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's transforming into the butt cheeks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yes, exactly.
That's the...
We chopped off this for the surgery.
For the surgery, to make it more cheeked up, we cut off the tail and used it as an implant.
Oh, no.
The tail becomes the butt implants.
It's like Fullmetal Alchemist.
Oh, yes!
Equal exchange, you know?
We Fullmetal Alchemist your tail into a butt cheek.
Fullmetal Alchemist, that's true, that's true.
I mean, it does work.
But, oh my gosh, my chat is like, Mimi gets a Twitch bot part 2.
Because I was getting a Twitch bot once when I was rigging.
I think something slipped through.
Now I'm scared all the time whenever I'm rigging.
Oh my god, wait, can you do that?
What?
What do we do?
The jiggle of the butt.
Yeah, I'm adding the jiggles on the butt.
Oh my god, oh, it's perfect.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We want to have a...
Not this one moves a little bit too much.
Maybe a little bit less.
Like one is moving more than the other.
Oh wait, now there's like...
What happened to...
Wait, wait, wait.
There's still one butt cheek.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Okay.
Okay, okay, now we have...
Okay, this one is a little bit buggy, but no problem, let's see.
And then, how do we...
Oh, now we will have butt cheeks physics whenever, wait.
Butt cheek physics.
Okay, how does it form?
Wait, wait, wait.
It will appear now in a second, like I just need to...
I don't know where the arm is going.
The arm was searching for something.
He's like, where is it?
I can't, I'm dying.
There was a premature arm there, right there.
He's like, where is it?
Oh, wait.
Like now, even if it appears atop this...
Oh wait, what happened to...
Wait, wait, what's going on with the butt?
Like, imagine...
It appears...
Oh my god, look at the jiggle on the butt!
Oh my god, look at the pierce!
That's so nice.
I'm just crying.
And now we need to edit the angles to the butt.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Body Y angle.
I forgot about my T, guys, so don't be...
Oh, you should get your T!
Yeah, yeah, you keep rigging, I'll be right back.
Okay.
Okay, chat, we are alone.
No one saw my butt thing, right?
That's good, no one saw that.
I'm scared Twitch is not going to ban me, right?
Builders?
I hope not.
Imagine.
Yeah, only...
This is a chicken's butt.
I think this is safe to go.
This is safe to go.
Chicken butt.
Oh, I'm dying.
If someone would have told me, like, I would rig a chicken's butt in two years...
Never I would have imagined I would do it.
I can't save anyone from you.
I want to rig those butt cheeks.
They are so funny.
I really love Curse rigging things.
Not gonna lie, they're so funny.
I really love that.
Life is very strange.
YouTube save.
Yeah, that's actually true.
YouTube save, but Twitch can't be a real meanie.
Twitch doesn't like...
butt physics.
She can't be stopped anymore, even without talking.
No, never.
And every one of you can have fun with those, with this little feller.
Like...
Imagine having...
Oops, I always put the...
Like...
We only need to connect the butt.
And it will be so funny.
Ah, wait.
Wait.
Wait a minute, we need to connect the leggies to it.
We want to have them connected to the chicken.
And...
Like this.
We can add the...
Chicken butt.
What I need to see...
Oh my god.
Look at him go.
Yes.
What the fuck is wrong with the butt?
It comes up.
Oh my god, he's a freak.
Look at this.
Oh, we need to fix the arm here, you know.
It's not...
It's not doing anything saucy, okay?
Oh my god, he's beautiful.
My little freaking boy.
Like, look at this now here.
This is the base we have so far.
Yeah, but his tail is gone.
Yeah, right now because I'm scared of what's happening right now when the butt is activated.
And then here...
We need to...
We need to change how the butt works right.
Right now it looks like the...
Dragon is moving, but without the...
But his butt stays on the same.
I like how, like...
The butt physics is, like, so much more advanced than any...
Anything else.
It's a special...
Wait, wait, what if I...
Wait.
Okay, right now this works.
And now we can...
No, I always...
So, and then we add...
I think, like this.
I mean, it looks still wrong, but I think it will work out.
At least it has a butt.
We should be thankful.
You should be thankful.
Guys, the surgery might not be a success.
We put it in the wrong area.
Just a tiny bit, but at least it's there.
At least it's there.
That's the most important thing.
Sorry, the surgery...
We might have botched the surgery a little bit.
But at least it looks good.
At least the jiggle is there.
What's happening there?
I have no idea.
It has a very...
Actually, wait.
It wasn't as equivalent as the exchange as it was.
I have no idea.
At least I want my tail back.
Guys, this is better than a tail.
What do you mean?
Guys, no.
Don't sue for medical malpractice, guys.
I think...
Okay, look.
Even though it was placed wrong...
It still...
At least it looks good.
What if we have it like this now?
Now, it's wrongly placed.
But it has always the butt with the toggle.
As long as, you know...
It's fine.
The butt is a little bit wrong.
Why is it...
Can we not make it disappear when he's facing in the front?
I was gonna say like...
Are we gonna move it to the front?
Wait, is that TOS if we move that to the front?
I would be scared.
Imagine getting banned for that.
Banned because of a chicken butt.
Could be me, I swear.
My luck would be like this.
Okay, like...
Okay.
This is going to be the worst.
My butt's up here.
Oh no, I have so many of them.
Yeah, like...
When it's over there, I think the butt shouldn't be showing.
Can I have it here?
But this is going to be so hard to have it here.
The butt comes out from nowhere from the back and the front.
Hello, here I am.
I just...
I want to be here too.
Hello.
I'm here.
I see double chin.
Oh no.
It's coming out.
Can we...
Can we get them to work with this part of it?
Just curious.
This is the most time we spent on the rigging part, by the way.
The butt has taken most of our time.
It's the most important part.
This is absolutely the most important part of rigging.
You think about this.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, yeah, yeah, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Further down, further down.
No, it should be further down.
No, no, no.
Oh my god.
The double chin.
Oh, you're...
Yeah, yeah.
And then...
Wait, remove the last one.
Remove the second one.
This one?
Yeah, yeah.
And then, can you make the line to the left just...
This was your chat.
This is not on me.
Wait, can you give him eye bags?
Can you give him eye bags?
Oh, eye bags.
Let me see.
Like...
I mean, this is like...
Like, if we can...
Wait a minute.
Okay, but then darken the bags a little bit.
Let me see.
Let me see if it's possible.
I think I did good.
Yeah, yeah.
Keep darkening a little bit.
A little bit more to this color.
I mean, let me make the line here a little bit more rounded for this part.
Oh my god!
This is really depressing.
Okay.
Here we go.
Here we are.
This impression has gone too far.
Oh, then we have...
What the fuck?
What was that?
You just like...
Maybe I've rigged everything on the butt.
What?
But this looks very wrong, like...
This is how your boobs would have been.
You should keep that.
No, you should keep that.
That's good.
I can keep that, but after stream.
Because I know for sure if it's...
If it's looking like a boob, but just a little tiny bit.
But this is...
That's great.
Special.
Okay, okay.
So, what else do we have to do?
We could add now physics to the...
Of course, to the double cheeks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, first of all, the hair.
Let's add the hair.
Only happy little accidents, guys.
Wait, what the fuck happened?
What happened?
Butt cheeks are making a dance party.
Oh my god.
These are things that can help very easily if you...
Not undo the params.
Like, now it's working, like...
Okay, okay.
I was like, what happened?
Oh, you look so depressed.
You look so sad.
No, don't be sad.
Turn to the left.
Don't be sad when you turn...
Wait, wait, when you turn to the left, you won't be sad anymore.
Oh, you gotta fix that.
You gotta fix that.
Wait, wait, we make the butt disappear.
But let me add the toggle for the chin.
Extra chin.
No, you guys look beautiful.
You guys look so beautiful.
The sad twerking.
I was starting with this being like...
Like a special gift for the community.
And now, what have I done?
It is so special.
What have I done?
It's so special.
I think they love it.
The saggy is a dragoon.
Depressed dragoon.
Here we are.
This cake is all I have.
No, we delete.
Oh, like we have the Ivex toggle.
You guys look so cool.
What do you mean?
For the extra chin toggle, we can make it more...
More funny appearing.
Like coming out here.
And then it appears like...
Like this.
It looks a little bit...
Like it's just growing.
It's good.
I love it.
It's so special.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, we have the arm jiggles.
Let me add this with the upper part here.
This one.
Let me connect those lines because it looks weird.
And let me see how it looks.
I always check out...
Like, look at this.
Look, this looks so squishy.
It's so squishy.
See, look at that, guys.
You look beautiful.
See?
Just trust the process.
Yeah, trust the process, guys.
Look at that.
It's beautiful.
I know.
It looks so cute.
And now what we can do is like making an eye animation.
I need to save my model before...
Oh yeah, true.
It would suck if we just lost everything.
After everything we went through.
Imagine.
No, this would be so sad.
So, here we are.
We add the eye animation.
That is the animation for the eyes.
Now, that makes it like open.
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you done?
For the base settings, yes.
Wait, no.
We didn't add water balloons.
Yes, yes.
Don't worry.
We wanna add them.
We will add them.
I just gotta be sure that we remember the most important part.
I just need to be sure we remember the most important part of this entire project.
This is very important.
Let me save them here.
I can add them.
But just let me do one thing.
I want to add the idol for it.
Because I want to have the idol for it, like...
Here?
Having it a little bit...
You should like, unsync his play so it's like...
Yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah, so one eye first.
Yes, you know exactly what I mean.
Then...
We open this one up.
We wait with the other one a tiny little bit.
Open it up.
So, let me see.
We just add this.
And now, we are going to add the balloons.
Yes.
Oh, you see the balloons I sent you?
Yes, I downloaded them.
Good thing is, I can just import it here.
As new art mesh.
Yeah, so...
So, we can make it smaller or squish it a little bit.
If needed to be.
And then...
Oh my god, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Is that bannable?
When you...
There should be a toggle where it just spawns in when you're teabagging.
Oh my gosh!
No, I would...
No, I wouldn't do that.
Okay, okay.
I can edit for you.
Don't...
No problem.
I can edit for you.
But...
Doing that on stream can be...
Okay, okay.
And then...
Do you think you can add jiggle fixes on a PNG?
Of course I can.
I can't...
I can't have, like, different...
But we can do something.
Let me try.
Let me try some...
Or we can create our own water balloon and just copy the design.
Oh, wait.
I have the idea of ideas.
Wait.
Delete this here.
I add them in Photoshop and this just...
Put them into blue balloon and...
Water balloon.
Or just...
That's perfect.
We can do it.
As nothing is impossible.
Imagine that then for cheap bagging.
I can't get those out of my head.
I will do that.
I need to do it later.
It's so funny.
So, what I'm having here right now is...
Balloons.
I'm going to cut them.
They are very simple, so...
I hope it will be relatively fast.
Wait still.
I don't use Photoshop so often.
Where is my magic tool?
Here.
My...
This one.
We are going to erase this part here.
So we have the...
Oh, just the blue?
And I will use the blue one.
Copy-paste it and make it in a different color.
Because then it will work too.
Because then we have two balloons.
That's true.
It's super easy.
Oh, she's cooking.
She's cooking, guys.
This is her idea.
Remember, this is her...
Remember, this is her idea.
I mean, I had some questionable ideas.
But that's not...
I'm innocent in this one.
And now we copy...
Not this one.
Copy-paste this one.
And have it in a different color.
Which one do we like to get?
I think orange was good.
I think orange was really good.
Let me get something similar to orange.
I'm not so good with...
Let me try this.
And then we get some colors on there.
Like...
Then we get some saturation.
I'm just trying to get near this.
Oh, wait.
I can do it like this.
Wait.
We take the exact color from this one, actually.
And put it in here.
She's cooking.
Then we take this one.
Put it in here.
And we take this one.
So, okay.
We have it.
Okay, we are done.
We're adding this one now.
As a PSD.
And we have our balloons ready.
And left and right separated, actually.
That's a good thing.
So...
Save under...
Balloons.
And then we can include that into this file.
Here.
Now we have them separated here.
Okay, okay.
You want one in each hand?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So like...
No, no, no.
It should be in front.
Yeah, right here.
Can we like...
Oh, we can make it like...
Yeah, right here.
And then the arms will hold on to it.
And then when you go up and down, the balloon starts jiggling.
Okay.
Easy peasy.
Holding arms.
So we copy-paste now...
Those arms and make a toggle.
Main arms.
Yeah.
So...
Toggle is...
Main arms.
No.
Balloon.
Balloon holding.
So for the balloon holding, we are going to make them...
Do it a little bit easy now.
Because I will make the transition later.
Uh-huh.
To make sure we go fastly to the ultimate...
Jiggle physics of the balloons.
This is very important.
We need those.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
I understand.
So...
Why is the chin still there?
Oh, oh, oh.
I mean...
I like...
My chat was like, why is it still there?
Do we want the...
The arm should be a little bit above, right?
Like, it should be above the balloons.
This means like...
Here?
What do you think?
It should be placed like this, maybe?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes.
Also, let me add the tail again.
The tail was gone for too long.
Oh my god.
Look at it.
Yes.
Now we have some balloons.
It's beautiful.
So, I'll have here this one and...
We add the balloon toggle here.
Balloons.
Here.
On body Y, so they will move already with the body.
Like, this looks awkward.
It has everything on it.
So, I'll delete this.
And we make...
The balloon toggle here.
Balloon toggle.
Guys, this is the final stretch.
After this, the dragoon is basically like done.
Wait, right?
Yes.
Oh, this is the last thing.
This is the last thing for our dragoons.
We can...
I would add all those things you mentioned before.
I will add them still for the community.
And I will send it to you.
So, you can just post it or release it.
Or I just post it on my Twitter.
I am Thomas Edison.
Our group project together that we made.
Working together, guys.
We worked so hard together.
I'll be Thomas Edison.
I'll be my Oshie.
I can be just like my Oshie.
Oh my god.
So, this is the balloon toggle.
Here we are.
I just wrote balloon golding.
I mean balloon holding.
Not golding.
So, here this is...
This is on like...
It's alright, Arnold.
We make it on one so...
It's just like balloon time.
It's balloon time.
It's a fun time.
He's like holding his balloon.
He's like...
So...
Oh, wait.
Let me get this camera thing out of the way.
Here we are.
So, now we need to add this a little bit to the angles, you know.
I want that they take it with them.
Okay.
We just make it very simple because we're going to add those physics here.
Oh, this is buggy.
I'll do it later.
First of all, the wonderful balloons.
Now, of course, we go low.
This looks...
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
It brings the villain.
He puts the balloon down.
Like, now we are here, but don't worry.
So, this one here was going to get changed.
Okay.
So, now we are rigging the...
Why is this so above?
What happened there?
Why is this here?
Don't worry.
I got that.
Here.
No.
What do you think?
Maybe, like, here?
Folding?
Here.
We have it, like, here.
Okay.
Okay, now we...
Oops.
Okay.
Balloon R.
We make them separate into L and R for a little bit more dynamic.
For up and down.
Like, you know, when they slam, like...
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Someone put a brawn.
Oh, like, brawnless.
Wow, Dragoon.
Let them swing free, I guess.
Let them free.
They need some fresh air.
Free the balloons.
Balloon one.
Y1.
For Y1, we make them, like, you know...
It's filled with water.
That means, like, we need to stretch it a little bit.
Oh, that's true.
And make them here together.
And make them up.
Okay.
I agree.
We are just making balloons.
That's very important.
Yeah, guys, they're just balloons.
Oh, my God.
That's what you do.
That's what you get for freeing the balloons.
That's true.
And actually, like, logical, we have here this tiny thing.
It would stretch to this part, so...
Goes this up, and then this a little bit down.
I just like this.
And then, of course, we have the arm physics for it.
Arm with balloons.
Because they move with the balloons.
Yeah.
Like this, right?
So, the arm goes a little bit down.
Then a little bit up.
And, of course, the balloon, too.
Like having...
A little bit less.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Let me see.
Let's see how we've done this.
Oh, wait.
We need another R physics.
R2.
Balloon.
Guys, we're learning how to do jiggle physics, guys.
But on water balloons.
Of course, water balloons.
That's the most safe...
Yeah.
That's just water balloons, guys.
I've never been a kid before holding your water balloons.
So...
Balloon Y.
We make the balloon Y now.
Take this.
Add one of...
Two physics points.
And let's see how this will look.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Maybe this one one.
This looks so fun.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay.
Can we add that to the orange one?
Wait, wait, wait.
I have another...
I have another R physics.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, my God.
We add this.
We need to get them slam together if we add this one.
What?
You gotta get them to slam together.
Oh, my God.
This is important, okay?
That's so important.
No, guys, she knows exactly how physics work, guys.
She...
She knows how it works.
She knows how the physics works, guys.
It's very important.
So, so, so.
Now we add the physics here.
Yeah.
We make one for the Y now.
Of course, I forgot to take my param again.
I just say it because I'm nervous.
Why are you bringing water balloons?
We are making this together.
And now...
This is the important part.
I really love the stretchy physics.
You sure do.
I can tell you are very experienced with these stretches.
I call them the...
Actually, I don't have a name for them.
I thought I would be faster with a name, but nope.
I call them the physics of doom.
It's just...
It's just chicken physics.
It's like pudding physics.
It's pudding.
Boing, boing, guys.
Look, he's having fun.
Look at him go.
I love it.
It's beautiful.
Look at it go.
Let me see how this looks.
It's a lot of trial and error until you are happy with those physics.
Now you can see here, the physics goes a little bit more down to the orange.
And I like this a little bit more.
It's good that it's not the same, too.
Because it's like, you know...
The left side is bigger, you know.
Look at this.
Yay.
Imagine you would have them on a different position.
Oh my god.
What would it look like if there's...
Okay.
What would it look like if she looks left side with it, too?
Left side and then...
Or right side and then with the butt.
Let me just see why the tail is...
So funky here.
Wait, is this tail long?
You want the shorter tail?
Because the shorter tail goes so far up and I have no idea why.
He's very happy.
He's just happy to sleep.
He's tired.
Yes, that's right, Dragoon.
Dance for me.
Okay, okay.
So now we have this one.
It's so...
It's beautiful.
Oh my god, wait.
Is it done?
Albus, Albus.
We got it, Albus.
Just a second.
Right.
We need to add the...
Physic for the balloons on X and then we are done.
Oh my god.
And then...
I can't believe we did all of this within like two hours.
That's crazy.
Yes.
Only the X now here.
We add this for this one, too.
And then we are done.
And then we see how it looks fully.
Okay.
We did it, guys.
So...
And now, balloon X.
I just forgot the second L, but no problem here.
And now we need to...
We put this into the numbers and then...
Oh my god, guys.
Look at you go.
Yes.
So now this is it.
This is what we've done on stream.
Of course, before sending out, I would just adjust some things to make it more fitting.
Adjust some stuff and add the auto toggles and adjust a little bit to...
Oh my god, guys.
And then you are free to do whatever you like with it.
Oh my god, everybody.
That was beautiful.
She did all of this within two hours.
That's actually crazy.
We had special requests, guys.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
Wow, that was actually really interesting.
Thank you for like...
I'm glad we did this as our collab.
That was very interesting to see and everything.
That was a very nice experience, not gonna lie.
You're welcome.
I was very happy and it was super fun to show some things off.
I'm not banned on Twitch, so...
See, she's okay.
It's not my fault, guys.
Minya is okay, guys.
But yes, please check her out on Twitch.
She does a lot of rigging stuff and she also plays a lot of video games as well on her Twitch.
But yeah, it was a great experience.
Let me link your Twitch real quick for those who want to check her out.
Thank you so much.
But yeah, thank you.
That was such a great experience in general.
I felt like I learned a lot.
I don't know how you did all this, but...
I feel like I learned a lot in general, even though I don't know what you did.
Also, I want to say thank you to the one that was recommending me, Alex.
Yeah, huge shoutout to Alex for setting this up for us.
But it was really nice to meet.
This is our first time actually talking in voice together.
Because we were just organizing this collab and I'm really busy too.
It was sort of really difficult to organize because I was sick, then I was busy, then I was sick again.
Then I got better and then I got sick again.
But we made it.
We made it.
We're finally here.
But yes, thank you again.
It was really great talking to you.
It was really great meeting you too.
I had a great time.
Thank you.
But please, feel free to check her out.
Follow her on Twitch.
Show her some love.
But thank you again.
I had a great experience and we did some really fucked up shit, but...
I can't wait to...
I can't wait to release the Dragoon for people.
I hope we can see many people playing with it.
Imagine.
Do you have any final words you want to say?
I was super nervous at the start.
But I'm so happy it went so well.
Thank you, Doki, for this nice experience.
It was super funny.
Yeah, it was.
It was actually really...
It was so fun.
But thank you again.
Yes, if you want to actually learn more about rigging, I know like...
I'm pretty sure in your own solo streams, you do teach more about the rigging process.
Rather than us fucking around.
Adding Jingle Physics to everything.
Why did you laugh so hard?
I'm gonna go rest my voice now.
Thank you again.
I'm gonna talk to my Dragoons real quick.
And I guess you'll talk to...
What are your fans called?
Yes, I will do as well.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, thank you.
Rest well.
Thank you.
Yeah, my voice is so dead right now at this point.
I laughed too much.
Alright, thank you again.
I'll see you next time.
Bye-bye.
I'm gonna talk to my Dragoons now.
Oh my god, okay, my voice is so dead now.
I laughed way too much.
It was a great experience.
I am going to rest my voice, because I do have a meet and greet for TakuFest and a panel later today.
So, I have 3, 4, 5...I have 4 hours to rest my voice.
So, thank you again, everybody!
A huge shout-out again to Alex for bidding on a charity auction collab and letting me meet Mimyoi.
And I had a great time talking to her throughout the stream and just doing all these crazy shit.
I'm gonna rest my voice now, as always.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check, get a move-around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
Tonight, 5PM stream is cancelled, by the way.
The stream at 5PM is cancelled, because you didn't listen to me.
Anyway, bye, everyone!
Bye!
Where's my ending screen?
Oh, there it is.
Bye!